Speaker 1: All right. Well, we have another
possible crime that Donald Trump or people
around him may have committed. This one relates
to what I call a revenge audit by the IRS.
This is a couple of things to understand about
this. And one, of course, is that what we have
right now is something circumstantial
and suspicious that is increasingly being
focused on Trump and people around
him. We don't yet know the full story,
but this is Salon has reported on the reality that
both James Comey and Andrew McCabe were subjected
to IRS audits. Now, these audits are very rare.
And so to see two high ranking FBI officials,
both targeted by audits that have a one in 30,000
per year prevalence, it starts to raise some red
flags. Former FBI Director James Comey and his
top deputy, Andrew McCabe faced rare, intensive
IRS audits after investigating former President
Donald Trump, according to The New York Times.
Comey, whom Trump fired in 2017 and McCabe, who
was similarly as Comey fired after investigating
Trump, were selected for, quote, random audits
known as autopsy without the benefit of death.
These are like the most invasive audits out
of about 153 million individual tax returns
from 2017. Only 5000 people were selected
for this type of invasive audit each year.
Now we'll get to the math. Okay. But the point
is, these are extremely rare. And for the former
f, the FBI director and the former FBI deputy
director to both be targeted by these audits,
it starts to be a little strange. Comey, McCabe
and their spouses defied the odds being selected
for the audit after being fired. The two men
were selected for an IRS research program that
uses compliance research examinations to try
to catch tax cheats. Unlike typical audits,
these audits force individuals to produce bank
records, copies of checks, receipts and letters,
effectively recreating their finances for the year
in question. This takes months and often costs
thousands in accountant fees. In my experience,
and I've not been audited, but in talking to
accountants about it, it's more than thousands
for this. This this could be tens of thousands.
The IRS said in letters to both men, your federal
income tax return for the year shown above
was selected at random for a compliance research
examination. We must examine randomly selected tax
returns to better understand tax compliance
and improve fairness of the tax system.
The minuscule chance of the two top FBI officials
being selected at random raised questions about
whether Trump appointees in the government or IRS
purposely targeted them. Lightning strikes. And
that's unusual. And that's what it's like
being picked out for one of these audits,
said IRS commissioner, former IRS Commissioner
John Koskinen. The question is, does lightning
then strike again in the same area? Does it
happen? Some people may see that in their lives,
but most will not. Trump's spokeswoman has
denied even knowing about these audits. Okay,
so let's do some math. And I know the math is not
easy on this, so I know that the math people will
tell me whether I'm wrong. So first first things
first. If the odds of this audit is one in 30,000
or the odds are one in 30,000. If you say what are
the odds of two specific people facing the same
audit, you would get one in 900 million, assuming
that every person is equally likely to be audited.
That doesn't really reflect the situation
in particular because you would imagine
that a large number of might. My guess is
that even if we believe the audits are random,
they're probably not being done for people below
a certain level of income. And that would probably
be for two reasons. One, that the amount that the
IRS even stands to recover from someone who might
have cheated on their taxes if they made 40 grand
is very, very low. So so that's one thing. And
number two, the mechanisms that are often used
to avoid taxes or evade remember avoidance and
evasion are two different things. One is legal,
one is not are much more commonly used by people
of higher incomes. So it's it's not even the right
number because it's not the entire population
that is probably even really at risk for this type
of audit. It's some subset of that above a certain
income level. Okay. But the other thing about
this is that there's the missing context of, well,
it's actually four people because it's these two
guys and their spouses and I believe they were in
different years. So if your risk of this is one in
30,000 each year, if we look over like the three
year period where Trump could have theoretically
directed. If this are indicated, someone should
do this. Then it's sort of like three in 30,000.
It gets complicated. But I think what we have to
understand are a couple of things. One, this is
very rare. And two, to see both of the top FBI
people targeted with this supposedly randomly
during a time when they were adversarial to
the president who appointed people to the IRS. We
know the president is one of the most vindictive
and childish, probably the most vindictive and
childish president that we've ever had. It is
weird. And so I'm not ready to say Trump directed
this. I'm not ready to say it was even necessarily
within Trump's purview. But it's strange enough
that it should be investigated. And one of the
things we have to remember also is like, imagine
that it was something Trump did. In theory,
this is a federal crime. But Trump really exposed
how easy it is to just ignore all of the checks
and balances on people in positions of power.
And if this was a retaliatory IRS audit, whoever
directed it, aside from whoever did it, should
be investigated, should be charged, if that's
what that's what happened. But Trump flouted all
sorts of different norms in checks and balances,
and at least for now, there have not really been
any consequences. So we learned that the framers
set up some checks and balances, but they clearly
assumed no one would ever flout them. That's flow
duty to the degree that Donald Trump did. And so
how strong are those checks and balances if they
can be ignored with essentially no consequences?
We will continue to get answers to that.